ادوات قمع النظام تخطت حتى سيارات الاسعاف
التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل ويبدو ان
المرشد لا يتردد في فعل اي شيء لاسكات
المعارضين وهكذا ترى واشنطن التظاهرات في
ايران لا يمكن تبريره استخدام العنف
المفرط ضد المتظاهرين وان حصلت نادم
بالتخريب في احيانا سلامه الشعب اهم من
سلامه الممتلكات العامه الامن منفذ والامر
والامر هو المرشد وتعزيز الفضيله مبداسه
في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ولهذا انشئت وحده
شرطه الاخلاق ومهمتها فرض قوانين اللباس
الاسلاميه على النساء والفتيات في الاماكن
العامه لكن ما يدور خلف الابواب عكس كل ما
هو اخلاقيه شبكه روسيا انا حققت ولي شهرين
ورود القصه التي تدور خلف قضبان السجون
الايرانيه والقصه تبدا من هذه النقطه
تحديدا من معبر الحاج عمران بيقسم المنطقه
يقسم المنطقه ذات اغلبيه كرديه تمتد من
غرب ايران الى شمالي العراق وبعد
الاحتجاجات خفت حركه عبور العائلات
الكرديه عبر الممر الحاجز تحول الى مصيده
للهاربين من القمع لكن حاجه العبور
لكردستان زادت لتصبح الجبال العراق هي
السبيل فطريق الموت كان اهون من مراكز
الاحتجاز للنظام وذلك بشهاده المعتقل
السابقه هانا لمده 24 ساعه عاشت هنا ومعها
40 امراه وعشارات الاطفال لحظات رعب
ووحشيه لا توصف تفاصيل المكان هذا هي
الاقرب لما تمكنت هانا من ان تتذكره هنا
في حي اسلام اباد في اورنيا كانت الفتيات
ينقلنا من القاعه الرئيسيه الى احدى غرف
الاستجواب ويتم الاعتداء عليهن حسن الحب
خرجت هنا بكفاله من والدها لكن الاخريات
هي عشنا مصيرا مجهولا يحيط به الرعب في كل
لحظه